ん
うん
読後前かわかんないよそこそここれあってなってるこんにちははじめ冊をで今日は何の
日か知ってますか
ただまたはいというわけで本日は七夕でございますよみんな基本的には多分短冊に
願い事を書くとそれがかなうかもしれないというね
昔からのそういうなんか抗弁とチックなものがあるんですけども僕はですね
やっぱりみんなの願い事を書かれたいなと
んだかと僕も僕も書かれたいですやっぱり笹の葉見てると言われましーんだと思った
からって何で今日はこれでちょっと今から町に入ってたってて私て皆は米シーン短冊が
付いてる人がいると願い事を書いてくれるのか鉄道が事件で育毛ねあれでは良いことで
みんなの願い用の僕の身体ずに込めてもらってロイ七夕にしましょう
というわけで町に入って選ん人の人が
全身が短冊の人に願い事を書いてくれるのかという検証していきたいと思いますや
行こう
みんなの願いを叶えにまずだがいるんだと思います
をそれだったら教えて強い
ん
ます
me
なちゅれちゃったんだけどえっ
誰ですかーや僕はさまざまぁね違う違う違う違うな俺は違うのにいいけど
e 4 e 1
違う俺たらこれ誰の言葉ですねばいばい
ん
雷声ハッピーさがバター
さっきのことよくこれで俺 tv ため逆にんハッピーかなぁ
はあああああ
ん
r ん
dare
me
ああああああ
car
me
wh
car
ああああああ
3種
ています